hello youtube just Louis this is region
here and welcome to my second chest
puzzle now you are watching the board
from the black side because this board
doesn't have nutritions like ABC or one
two three
I'm giving you idea how all pcs are
positions so you're reading the board
from the black side and let's say black
King on at six and if I can flip the
view which is on the white side rookies
on g8 so now it's in this fellow this is
why to move now pick which side you're
gonna win this win this game so like
before you going into the puzzle let me
tell you one thing that this puzzle is
not like you can mate opponents in two
three or five shapes you have to think
more deeper lines so just don't try to
like you know go in a mate like two
three or five now if you have picked the
black side in this puzzle you're on
because in this puzzle white gonna win
now consider yourself as a white and
think like think in a broader
perspective like how you win how you
made the black so okay let's go step by
step what will be the first move the
white ok first move the white is but
obvious is giving a check to the black
king and here black King has only one
step which is going here now what will
be your second step okay second step
also will be a more common which is
moving group over here and now here
black King can't go on h6 square because
it will made by a discovered check of
Bishop and back will lose the Queen so
black King has to go to the HF square
now think what you gonna pay here what
we'll do the base move of the white and
the base move the white here is moving
this fishable here so what the love is
it will attacking on the black Queen so
black Queen has
to move somewhere so but here Blackman
has only one square left which is
blacking has to go to the even scrap now
what what he will play as a white what
will be the best white move over here
and if you are good chess player you can
easily identify the situation and here
the best move for the white is to moving
the bishop over here now what it does is
because this scenario and the scenario
black king kong' can't move anywhere and
now what it does is there's only two
options left for the black black side
now either black can attack on the white
bishop or black queen has to find a
place where you can hide from the
discover check of the room so black
pants black side has to keep in mind
with this these two things and here
let's take two options there's only two
options left for the black side now
let's take the first option where black
queen take the pawn and take the
opportunity to check the White King and
to be your surprise
why King will move to the h1 square and
some of you think that white is really
full he should move to the g2 g1 square
either natural square but and maybe
after watching this board right now he
will be thinking yeah black is much
stronger and apart from the discovered
check of the white there is nothing left
on the white side but after this move
the white you will be surprised how
sometimes we come to a situation where
it seems to be really hopeless but it's
converting into the winning situation so
what you will be playing as a while and
the best move here for the white is
moving this King 2-2 Square and after
the stab just look at the black side
and you got my idea where where the
queen is hiding there is no place in the
bar where Queen is hiding and no matter
what black will play here the next step
of the white will be trapping the Queen
so anywhere the black queen will be
moved the white group gonna trap white
will take white rook will take the Queen
and the another thing is there is no
where black is like an attack on the
black and white Bishop so this is a
completely losing situation below black
so let's say black identify this and he
couldn't take that pawn and stir up that
he plays a nice move which is hide his
Queen and moving to the c-4 square but
it's nice and hiding now as a bride what
you gonna do well here White has a
really good move which is can you guess
it the best move here for the white is
moving this Bishop to the Avon Square
and now what it does is because now if
you can look at the black screen here
black Queen doesn't have any squares
left on it so only possibility and it's
a force full one which is black has to
move the pawn and now what white white
will do is move this Bishop again and
here again black has two possibilities
left either black can move the pawn
further or queen can attack the black
Bishop but I deal chair says that save
your pawn moves until you how to
forcefully move them so scenario like
this you have to attack the black like
your opponent
so what obvious is Queen has to attack
the fish up over here and what now what
has a white you we will do think
something broad like let's say if you're
repeating the same steps white will
reflect will repeat the same step and
nothing is coming out like hazard why do
you not getting anything so what he will
be do as a white well as a white you
to do a verse moon which is move the
bishop over here and what it does is
Queen has to move over here for example
let's say there's another good option
which is some of you can think that
why can't King Queen can attack the
White King but here after this Jack when
the King moves over here again to be a
surprise there is no like square left
for the black Queen and there's no way
White Queen can attack the like so black
Queen can attack the white bishop
so again doesn't matter where White
Queen Blackman will boo next step will
clapping the Queen so this step isn't as
nice
so again Blackman has to go to the sea
for square but now what it does is this
mission will go to the haven square and
it it wastes one move so back the black
has to move one step instead of moving
his Queen because here Queen can't move
anywhere so black forcefully again have
to move the pawn and white will continue
to same water sorry so until that pawn
go to the h2 square and this will be the
last time right will ripple repeat the
Moors and here that's it no matter where
the Queen will move like black rook will
take the Queen so that's the first
option now let's go to the second option
here you know that if you take that pawn
it will open a line and it will cause a
serious problem for your queen so I
can't be ignore that line let's play a
safer move for the black which is black
can play a really good move which is
moving Queen over here c1 and what you
will be play as a white well otherwise
you have to resolve your moves you have
to like move your others in such a way
that we come to a scenario in the first
first time we made them like you know
trap the Queen so otherwise you will be
playing Queen King over here
now if you can look at the blacks vision
over here black has a nice two steps for
the Queen which is hiding a c2 and a c4
so doesn't matter where the Queen is
moving over here let's say it's moving
to the c2 square black has white has a
really nice move so what what white will
do is first play a really safe or move
which is moving a queen king to the h1
square and now black has really two
possible square left let's say the first
square red queen is moving over here
attacking on the white bishop well here
white can simply retreat that Bishop on
even square and if the Queen goes over
here we already seen that it will be
trap so Queen has to retreat somewhere
so here there's only four square left
with c2 now here Y has a really smart
move which is moving this pawn further
and now what allow is only there's only
one square left for the black Queen
which is c4 and here what you will be
playing as a while and here believe it
not but the best move for the white is
just moving that point further and if
you can look at not with the position
over here they're the same position
which will come across before so has a
wide has a black you have to forcefully
play the pawn and we will come to the
same scenario where the same steps steps
will be repeating and until that pawn
goes to the h2 square so apart from this
this there's no or the situation left
Thanks there's no no not a single any
other motors which black can do so
unfortunately black has to play this
forcefully and then here that's it
black queen is running out of the steps
and
doesn't matter where the black minis
moves it will be trapped by the
black/white rule let's say if it's going
here white can simply play the rook over
here so black queen forcefully has to
take the bishop and white will easily
win this game so moral of this puzzle is
no matter what your situation is try to
identify a good theft lines don't give
up though any kind of positions try to
win it and sometimes you never know we
come come out like this a nice trap well
thank you for watching my video
and I'll put next puzzle soon see you
bye